نشرت كوريا الشماليه صورا قالت انها
للصواريخ الاخيره التي اطلقتها بما في ذلك
صاروخ بالستيون عابر للقارات معروف باي سي
بي ام ودنت كوريا الشماليه تدريبات
العسكريه المشتركه بين كوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده معتبره اياها استفزازا
مفتوحا وتدريبات حرب خطيره وجبل الرد
عليها وفق تعبيرها ووفقه بيان صادر عن
هيئه الاركان العامه للجيش السوري صباح
اليوم اكدت انها ستواصل الرده على
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه في اجراءات
عسكريه وصفتها بالحزمه
كما قالت كوريا الشماليه انها سترد على
التدريبات المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه باجراءات عسكريه مستدامه
وحازامه وكاسحه حسب ما ذكرته وكاله
الانباء الرسميه الكوريه الشماليه ونقلت
الوكاله كذلك عن هيئه الاركان العامه
للجيش الكوري الشماليه قولها ان التجارب
الاخيره التي اجرتها كوريا الشماليه على
صواريخ بالستيه تشكل ردا واضحا على واشنطن
والسهول بشان تدريباتهما المشتركه الاخيره
واضافت الهيئه انه كلما تواصل التحركات
والاعداء العسكريه لاستفزازيه واجههم
الجيش الشعبي الكوري بمزيدا من الدقه
والقسوه وفق تعبيره هيئه الاركان الكوريه
الشماليه